[Music]
Merry Christmas I
accidentally kissed the
person I love, and the way I treat the person I like is not like a normal quiche.I guess we
can call them lovers now.Other than that, it's a
good thing,
Chairman, are you okay?
[Music]
Show me,
Forget it.  I can't do it
[Music] Is it
Christmas? What will you do in
Kinomiya? The
first person you fell in love with is none other than me. Why are you
running away from me? Don't come any closer to me.
What on earth have I done to you?  I'm angry. I
need to tell the president. All I need to do is stay by your side. I'm just my true self. I don't
hide anything from people who like my normal voice. The
more I like someone, the more I love them.
Look at me and say,
]